the morning co-host stopped by an Encino
California strip mall in sweat pants and
flip-flops right now Billy Bush is
laying low and that's the only thing he
can do his agents his representatives
are in negotiations with NBC about an
exit deal in order to kind of clean this
up to the extent that it can be cleaned
up at all meanwhile back in New York I'm
Tamara alongside Carson and don't out
Carson Daly stepped in to Billy spot
this morning bad news for one TV stars
always good news for another star in
this case it could be Carson Daly
stepping in for the long term taking
over for Billy it's all just the latest
fallout from this now infamous leaked
video on it you can hear Bush and Donald
Trump make lewd comments a lot of people
are asking should Bush be fired from
today I definitely believe in second
chances but right now it's just not
possible to have Billy Bush co-host of
today's show this election is is too big
too complicated and he's a big story in
the election right now we did notice
this change in the today show's third
hour Billy and his co-hosts are usually
featured in the broadcast open and Billy
Bush well that part has been cut out
since yesterday the first day of Billy
suspension and Billy's social media
accounts are under scrutiny happy
Father's Day to me thank you Bush
deleted this Instagram video which
showed him joking about a topless maid
service she always asked me what do you
want Madison what do you want for
Father's Day I don't know meanwhile a
source at NBC tells ET that Bush was
bragging and real about the existence of
the Trump tape but did not tell his NBC
bosses about it in theory of big stars
on TV like Billy Bush have morals
clauses in their contract which gives
NBC a way out of his deal if they find
something that's embarrassing if he if
he hurts the company in some way well
Carson Daly is expected to fill in for
Billy again tomorrow